uh let's go next to our caller
from the 661 area code who's calling
today from
661. hey david
uh long time viewer here from
lancaster california and i just had a
quick question for you
sure the
rhetoric that trump and his campaign has
put
forth since his uh election since he
started running in 2015
i feel as though it's directly led to a
rise
in deaths of despair in america alcohol
you know liver disease suicide drug
overdose
and also just overall violent crimes
hate crimes things like that and i
actually
wanted to know if you had any thoughts
on that
any uh well no i have no particular
thought i mean so there's a couple
different sides to that
so deaths of despair often are related
to economic circumstances
and um certainly it would be a
counterpoint to the idea that before
coronavirus
things were better than ever because if
things were better than ever you would
not expect
many of these deaths of despair to be on
the increase now in terms of the hate
crimes and crimes targeting
religious minorities or ethnic
minorities or whatever the case may be
i i've said before i don't think trump
has
created racists or xenophobes and
whether trump is personally racist or
xenophobic is less relevant what matters
is
trump has made existing racists and
xenophobes
more comfortable to be out in public
with their views and has emboldened them
and so it's also not particularly
surprising but i think the deaths of
despair are sort of
a different phenomena than uh that than
some of these
hate crimes and other violence
okay i appreciate the answer and uh big
time
all right thank you yes that was the the
audio quality there was brutal i
apologize for that